BRIAN: ALEX OSSOFF -- ALEX AZAR
DIRECTING A SUPPLY OF DOSES TO
MAKE SURE VACCINATED AMERICANS
GET THEIR SECOND DOSE.
HERE’S DOCTOR SIEGEL, OUR
CONTRIBUTOR, MEDICAL EXPERT.
WHAT CHANGES WITH THIS NEW
RULE?
>> WE TARGET THOSE OVER 65.
VACCINES WON’T BE HELD IN
FEDERAL FREEZERS AND STATES
LIKE TEXAS, CALIFORNIA FLORIDA
WHICH HAVE ONE QUARTER OF THE
ELDERLY WILL GET MORE DOSES.
ALL THAT IS GOOD BUT REMEMBER
AS YOU WERE TALKING BEFORE WE
CAME ON 25 MILLION DOSES WERE
SENT OUT ALREADY AND ONLY 9 TO
10 MILLION HAVE BEEN GIVEN
MEANING A LOT OF SLOWDOWN IS
OCCURRING AT THE STATE LEVEL
BECAUSE OF TOO MUCH ADHERENCE
TO RIGID GUIDELINES.
EVEN THE HEAD OF CDC SAID WHAT
IS ALWAYS RIGID ADHERENCE, IT
HAS TO BE FLEXIBLE.
YOU CAN’T THROW OUT VACCINES.
IF YOUR STATES AS YOU ARE OVER
65 YOU QUALIFY, PATIENTS ARE
SAYING THE GOVERNORS SAYING
THAT IN NEW YORK BUT WHERE DO I
GO?
PLANS ARE NOT YET IN PLACE TO
GET EVERYBODY OVER THE AGE OF
65 VACCINATED.
WE NEED TO DO THAT AS SOON AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THAT IS WHERE
ALL THE ILLNESS AND DEATH IS
COMING OVER THE AGE OF 65.
BRIAN: STADIUMS AND ARENAS
MIGHT BE PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO
GO.
WISE THAT BETTER?
WHY NOW?
>> HUGE VACCINATION CENTERS ARE
WHAT WE NEED, THE FEDS CAN BE
INVOLVED IN THIS WITH THE
MILITARY.
THIS HAS TO BE A FULL-COURT
PRESS, 24/7, WEEKENDS AND WE
ARE NOT USING OUR ARENAS FOR
SPORTS, WE ARE USING THEM FOR
VACCINES.
BRIAN: THE PUSH TO GET KIDS
VACCINATED, YOU HAVE NOT
STUDIED IT FOR KIDS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW KIDS WILL
REACT TO THIS.
>> WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE WAS ALL THESE CRAZY
IDEAS ARE COMING OUT, TAKE ONE
SHOT INSTEAD OF TWO, HAS IT
BEEN STUDIED?
GIVE IT TO KIDS, KIDS UNDER THE
AGE OF 12 HAVEN’T EVEN BEEN
STUDIED WITH THIS VACCINE.
WE’VE GOT TO WAIT UNTIL THE END
OF CLINICAL TRIALS, THEY TEND
TO HAVE MILDER CASES IN SCHOOLS
OF DONE WELL STAYING OPEN AS IT
IS.
YOU CAN’T VACCINATE PEOPLE YOU
HAVEN’T STUDIED.
BRIAN: PEOPLE ASK HOW DO I KNOW
IF I’M ELIGIBLE?
WHERE DO THEY GO?
TALKING TO AN INTERNATIONAL
AUDIENCE, WHAT DO YOU TELL
THEM?
>> YOUR STATE MAY SAY SIGN UP
HERE BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO GO TO
YOUR PHYSICIAN, YOUR HOSPITAL
AND SAY WHO ARE YOU GIVING IT
TO?
WE ARE STARTING WITH PEOPLE